tobago Cologne I'm guessing that's you
I guess you guys haven't heard about me
have you I'm about sick of always having
to buy new clothes
hey youtubers it's Charlie sweet
Christmas new Luke Cage let's break it
down so I think this is actually from
the first episode the Cologne person
actually isn't tied to anyone
specifically from the comics with the
name that he calls out there is a Carly
cologne from the Ghost Rider comics but
you have to remember the Netflix series
like as many comic book characters as
they do they also introduced a lot of
original characters so part of the fun
of this you know I mean it's just really
like the first episode but you can see
the obvious visual references to
daredevil because of the boxing ring
he's in the gym very much in keeping
with the idea of fog wells Jim I think
he's in Harlem so I don't think that
this is fog wells Jim I think it's just
like some other place but it's just a
way for them to visually wink at the
other Netflix series they'll do the same
thing with jessica jones and the only
like real big crossover i'm expecting is
from iron fist that'll probably turn the
run the joke about buying new clothes
does make me wonder if Melvin Potter is
going to help like make him some shirts
that are more bullet resistant just so
he doesn't have to keep actually buying
new clothes but he's one of the few
characters that doesn't need to wear
Kevlar or anything like that like when
you have bulletproof skin it's not so
important that you wear body armor and
like you don't need Daredevils billy
club you don't need a weapon because you
are the weapon so maybe when we get to
defenders will see some sort of Melvin
Potter crossover where he makes him some
sort of outfit that doesn't get shredded
every time somebody lights him up with a
gun but they did have a nice week at the
classic 70s blaxploitation caught like
the tiara costume in the last trailer
that I posted him getting his powers
climbing out of the tank after had been
sabotaged like he just he has like these
nodes on him that looked just like the
tiara in the wrist cuffs from the comics
so think that's about as close as we're
getting to comic book costume like
daredevil is actually in danger of
getting shot so like that's why he needs
to wear body armor The Punisher needs to
wear Kevlar because he gets shot at a
lot too so you guys can let me know in
the comments do you think that Luke Cage
will ever wear any type of Melvin Potter
creation whether or not its armor or is
just something that's more bullet
resistant so he doesn't have to keep
buying new clothes but just reminder all
the episodes are dropping simultaneously
worldwide on September 30th so what I'll
do is like there'll be a couple more
trailers before it actually drops but
when it does drop I'll do videos just
like I did for Jessica Jones just like
daredevil season 2 so because there's 13
episodes they'll just be like
video for every 2 episode like I won't
be able to do 13 videos because it all
dumps at once so all my Easter eggs all
my episode videos will start dropping
September 30th i'll be doing a giveaway
while that's going on so just as a
reminder there are a couple comic book
series that are coming back that last
weekend at September including agents of
shield which is now a 10pm show so when
we get a little closer to that I'll do
like an agents of shield video explain
that it's a completely separate thing
because they're doing Ghost Rider
they're going to go to a later time slot
it's going to get bloodier there's going
to be more boobs it'll be a little more
in the tone of the Netflix series which
I think everybody's on board for but if
you guys haven't seen I've done a couple
Punisher videos it's like the next big
thing that's getting ready to roll out
iron fist is gonna drop in the spring
but they already finished shooting that
so we'll see more trailers for that but
they're going to start shooting the
punisher series early next year so we'll
probably start learning a lot more about
that later this year but if you guys are
looking for a Luke Cage comic book to
read right now you won't like some
backstory they did reboot Power Man and
Iron Fist like a Heroes for Hire title
after secret wards it's like the current
running title I would recommend you just
check that out it's a lot of fun you can
always go back and read like the really
old Luke Cage stuff there will be Easter
eggs for that but remember how the
daredevil series change some of the
comic book stories there'll be a lot of
Easter eggs for comic book stories but
they're not doing anyone in particular
for the season so get hype and keep your
eyes peeled for Danny ran I'm expecting
them to appear later in the series maybe
before episode 13 but at least by that
last episode next video tonight should
be Game of Thrones but I'm always taking
video requests originally I was going to
do that but it wasn't expecting them to
drop new Luke Cage footage so sweet
Christmas a lot more stuff coming
tonight what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to watch the
Civil War bloopers again and you can
click here to learn all about Odin vs.
Thanos and thor ragnarok thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight